I've had an absolute fascination with
sharks since I was a little kid
I knew I wanted to be a marine biologist
by the time I was five and I got to
snorkel with my first shark when I was
about eight years old and I was
literally hooked on these awesome
animals I'm Gillian Morris I am a shark
conservationist a shark diver and
underwater videographer I've traveled
all over the world and I have to say
that Bimini has some of the bluest
waters I've ever seen all different
shades some people joke about the 50
shades of blue and Bimini the island is
really really small it's about six miles
long but the world just below the
surface is really what's incredible that
blue crystal-clear water is teeming with
marine life and is the reason why we
live on this tiny little island the
great hammerhead dive site is about a
quarter of a mile offshore it's a place
where in very shallow water you're able
to get in and see these very large
sharks up close and personal it's very
rare to actually be able to be in the
water with so many of them like weekend
here in Bimini especially in
crystal-clear shallow water
unfortunately sharks get a really bad
reputation they're not man-eating
monsters they're not mindless eating
machines they're actually really
intelligent social incredible animals
they're also really incredible for the
health of our oceans which all of us
rely on every single day there's
something really special about
hammerheads I have been in the water
with some very big sharks including
great whites and tiger sharks but
nothing compares to the great hammerhead
the way they move
their power their grace they can turn on
a dime and they have those wide-set eyes
they're my favorite animal on the planet
and being able to dive with them as much
as we do I feel really really lucky
you